PETE: FOX NEWS CAPTURING VIDEO
OF CARTELS FIRING INTO THE
BORDER OF THE U.S.
RACHEL: PRESIDENT BIDEN’S BORDER
CZAR KAMALA HARRIS SKIPPING THE
HIGH LEVEL SECURITY TALKS WITH
MEXICAN OFFICIALS TO MAKE A TRIP
TO THE NEW JERSEY BAKERY TO LOOK
AT CUPCAKES AND THAT DELICIOUS
COCONUT CAKE.
WILL: DIFFER ON THE COCONUT
CAKE.
SENATOR BLACKBURN JOINS US LIVE
FROM MISSION, TEXAS WHERE SHE IS
GETTING A FIRST-HAND LOOK AT THE
CRISIS.
AS THE VICE PRESIDENT MIGHT
SOLVE THE DEBATE OVER AND I OVER
RACHEL COCONUT CAKES.
YOU WERE TAKING A FIRSTHAND LOOK
AT THE ISSUE AT HAND, SENATOR
BLACKBURN.
WHAT WE SEE IN THAT VIDEO IS
PRETTY SHOCKING.
THAT SEEMS TO BE A GROWING
CHAOTIC SITUATION IN TEXAS AND
MEXICO.
>> IT IS, INDEED A GROWING
CHAOTIC SITUATION, WILL.
AND THE BORDER PATROL AND ALL
THESE DOWN HERE IN OPERATION
LONE STAR HAD INVITED ME TO COME
DOWN AND SPEND THE DAY, WORK
WITH THEM, SEE FIRSTHAND, NUMBER
ONE ISSUE WITH TENNESSEANS IS
HAVING A SECURE SOUTHERN BORDER.
AND YOU WERE SHOWING THE FOOTAGE
OF THE FIRE.
WHAT IS SO INTERESTING, THE
CARTEL AND THERE ARE THREE
CARTELS THAT ARE WORKING DOWN
HERE, THEY HAVE GREAT RESPECT
FOR THE RULE OF LAW.
THE BORDER PATROL WANTS TO DO
THEIR JOB.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WILL
NOT LET THEM.
THE CARTELS ARE AFRAID OF THE
TEXAS NATIONAL GUARD AND TEXAS
LAW ENFORCEMENT, SO THEY’RE
GETTING REALLY BOLD BECAUSE THEY
KNOW BIDEN IS WEAK.
THEY KNOW THEY CAN START TO
CREATE MORE CHAOS HERE ON THE
BORDER AS THEY TRY TO FORCE THIS
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS HERE AT OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT, YOU
KNOW, THESE CARTELS ARE TAKING
SUCH ADVANTAGE.
AND ARE CAUSING SUCH HARM TO
THESE FAMILIES THAT ARE TRYING
TO COME IN TO THE U.S.
ILLEGALLY.
IT IS A VERY SAD SITUATION.
IT IS A DANGEROUS SITUATION.
AND AS I HEARD YESTERDAY FROM
RANCHERS, PROPERTY OWNERS, THE
CBP, THE TEXAS LAW ENFORCEMENT,
THIS IS A NATIONAL SECURITY, A
HUMANITARIAN AND A HEALTHCARE
ISSUE.
RACHEL: IT ABSOLUTELY IS.
I WILL TELL YOU, BEYOND THE
SPANISH LANGUAGE TELEVISION
THROUGHOUT THIS SINCE BIDEN HAS
BEEN ELECTED.
DOING THE SMUGGLING SPANISH,
WERE DOING THIS THE LAWS HAVE
CHANGED.
BIDEN SAYS WE CAN DO THIS.
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THIS SITUATION.
AND YOU ARE RIGHT, IT IS SO
DANGEROUS.
WHAT IS FASCINATING TO ME,
SENATOR, IS THAT WE WERE
SUPPOSEDLY GETTING KAMALA
HARRIS, WHO AS YOU SAW IS AT THE
BAKERY INSTEAD OF THE BORDER,
SHE WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
ADDRESSING THE ROOT CAUSES.
EVER SINCE THESE POLICIES HAVE
HAPPENED.
EVER SINCE SHE HAS BECOME BORDER
CZAR, THE CARTELS ARE STRONGER
THAN EVER.
AND THEY ARE CREATION MORE
CHAOS, MORE INSTABILITY IN
MEXICO AND CENTRAL AMERICA
BECAUSE THEY ARE RICHER THAN
EVER.
>> THAT IS RIGHT: THEY ARE
MAKING MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
I HAD A RANCHER YESTERDAY LOOK
AT ME AND SAID WHERE’S KAMALA?
I WANT TO KNOW WHERE SHE IS.
SHE WAS SUPPOSED TO SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM.
THE RANCHERS ARE HAVING TO SPEND
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS TO
PROTECT THEIR PROPERTY.
YOU HAVE FAMILIES COMING FROM
150 DIFFERENT COUNTRIES AROUND
THE WORLD AND THEY ARE SPENDING
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS TO
GET ACROSS THIS BORDER BECAUSE
THE CARTEL IS TELLING THEM OH,
YOU KNOW, WE’LL SMUGGLE YOU IN.
AND THEY ARE ENDANGERING THESE
CHILDREN.
SOME OF THESE CHILDREN ARE
COMING BY THEMSELVES.
RACHEL, IT IS HEART-BREAKING.
THEY HAVE FOUND CHILDREN WHO
HAVE DIED.
THEY HAVE FOUND CHILDREN WHO ARE
LEFT IN THE MIDDLE OF NOWHERE AS
YOUNG AS 5, 6, 7 YEARS OLD BY
THESE CARTELS.
THE CARTELS ARE NOT AFRAID OF
THIS ADMINISTRATION AND, AS YOU
SAID, RIGHT NOW, THEY ARE MORE
BRAZEN, THEY ARE BOLDER, THEY
ARE ENDANGERING THESE LIVES.
THEY KNOW THAT THE U.S. TAXPAYER
DOLLAR IS GOING TO HELP CARRY
THAT PERSON FROM THE WATERS EDGE
TO WHEREVER IT IS THEY ARE GOING
IN THE UNITED STATES.
AND AS YOU SAID, ALL THE TIME,
THE CARTEL GETS RICHER.
THEY ARE MAKING MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS EVERY WEEK.
THIS NEEDS TO STOP.
PETE: YOU ARE RIGHT.
SENATOR, WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR TIME.
UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE OUT OF
TIME.
YOU ARE DOWN THERE GETTING THE
REAL STORY WHILE THE VICE
PRESIDENT IS NOT.
WE ALSO KNOW YOU ARE ON TOP OF
THIS STORY.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL WHO IS
GOING AFTER PARENTS WHEN IT
TURNS OUT HIS DAUGHTER IS
ACTUALLY WORKING WITH GROUPS
THAT ARE PUSHING CRT.
WE ARE OUT OF TIME.
WE KNOW YOU ARE WORKING ON
MULTIPLE THINGS AT ONE TIME.
THE ADMINISTRATION NOT QUITE
CAPABLE OF THAT AND WE HOPE TO